en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo se definía
el producto de matrices a partir de la
idea de la composición de
transformaciones lineales dijimos que si
teníamos una matriz
la matriz que era de m por n
renglones y tiene columnas y también
teníamos una matriz b
la matriz ve que era de n porque ésta
tenía en el renglones y acá columnas es
muy importante que está n estã n
coincidan el número de columnas en ay el
número de renglones en b más adelante
veremos por qué pero bueno ve vamos a
decir que tiene la forma que ve es la
matriz cuyas columnas son los vectores
columna b 1
de dos en su segunda columna y así hasta
la calle sima columna tenemos cada
columnas así que hasta beca
esa de ahí es la matriz b y entonces
nosotros definimos a la matriz a por b
la matriz a por b como quien pues será
la matriz cuyas columnas eran
precisamente el resultado de multiplicar
a por cada una de las columnas la
primera columna de a por b sería a la
matriz a multiplicada por la primera
columna de la matriz b que sería a por
el vector columna de uno la segunda
columna sería a
toda la matriz y multiplicada por la
segunda columna debe
y así así continuar y amos
hasta llegar
multiplicada por la última columna de
versa por la k décima columna de b
bien esa fue nuestra definición de a por
b estaba inspirada en el hecho de que
queríamos que la composición de
transformaciones lineales lineales fuera
representada por la matriz que era el
producto de las matrices que
representaban las transformaciones
lineales ahora bien esto quizás suena
bastante bastante exacto y quizás no
coincida con la definición que ustedes
conocen de producto de matrices ahora lo
que sí les digo es que cualquier
definición que tengan de producto de
matrices va a ser equivalente a ésta
pero bueno vamos a hacer un ejemplo
concreto vamos a decir que tengo la
matriz am
vamos a hacer una matriz relativamente
pequeña vamos a considerar la matriz 1 -
1 2
0 - 2 1
una matriz pequeña con números pequeños
para que la aritmética no se nos salga
de control y también vamos a tener la
matriz b
la matriz ve qué va a hacer la matriz 1
0 1 1
1 - 1 y 3 1 0 2
bien es una matriz bastante pequeña así
que esta matriz de aquí esta matriz de
aquí es de 2 x 3 y esta matriz de acá es
de 3 x 4 de nuevo recuerden el número de
renglones en b tiene que coincidir con
el número de columnas en a muy bien
entonces por definición por nuestra
definición el producto de a con b va a
ser
la matriz cuyas columnas son el
resultado de multiplicar por cada
columna así que mi primera columna nada
por b para estar y esta vez será la
matriz a multiplicada por el vector 123
mi segunda columna sería la matriz a
multiplicada por el vector 001
y mi tercera columna sería a por el
vector 1 10
finalmente finalmente cuarta columna
sería la matriz a multiplicada por el
vector
1 - 12
muy bien
y de hecho esto ya nos da una razón en
por qué el número de columnas emaná
tiene que coincidir con el número de
renglones en b observen observen que si
llamo si llamó a cada columna de la
matriz b bueno de hecho ya las llame b1
b2 a esta beca entonces en este caso en
este caso
para cada uno dos tres o cuatro b y
pertenece a donde pertenece aire que
pues cada columna tiene tres entradas
así que pertenece a r3 y el producto de
una matriz por un vector como en este
caso sólo está bien definido cuando el
número de columnas de la matriz es igual
al número de entradas del vector así que
eso nos da una explicación de por qué
estos dos números tienen que coincidir
pero bueno continuando con lo que
estamos haciendo ya redujimos el obtener
el producto de a por b con obtener el
producto o más bien con el problema de
obtener estos cuatro productos de
matrices por vectores pero eso ya lo
sabemos hacer bastante bien así que no
debemos tener ningún problema ok
entonces
entonces a por ver quién va a ser
pues
veamos cómo definimos el producto de la
matriz a por el vector 123 pues si
recuerdan lo que hacíamos era
esencialmente tomar el primer renglón de
a
y hacerle el producto interior a tomar
el producto interior con el vector 123 y
hacer a mi primera entrada la segunda
entrada de ese vector era el segundo
renglón de a producto interior con 123
ahora bien ahí hay quizás hay algo
extraño porque esto no es un vector
columna por lo tanto como podría tomar
el producto interior con otro vector
columna pues lo que sucede lo que sucede
aquí
vamos a usar este modo lo que está
sucediendo es que si yo tengo un vector
a si yo tengo un vector ar
y digamos es cualquier cosa no x 1 x 2 x
entonces podría tomar el vector ha
transpuesto
si lo pienso como una matriz entonces
quién sería trans puesto pues sería
simplemente cambiar esta columna por un
renglón sería x 1 x 2 x 3
así que puedo pensar en los renglones de
mi matriz
como vectores transpuesto sectores
columnas tres puestos así que en
realidad lo que estoy haciendo es
tomando el producto interior de este
vector con el transporto de este renglón
déjenme le escribo quizás es aclare
mucho las cosas
como el primer renglón
y lo escribo como una columna 1 - 1 2
y eso lo voy a tomar su producto
interior con el vector 1
luego mi segunda entrada sería tomó el
segundo renglón de lo escribo como
columna
que sería 0 - 2 1
pero no equivocarme en este paso
y lo multiplicó por este vector como un
producto interior con el box vector 123
ahora bien puede usar otro color para ya
no estar cambiando
quién sería a por 0 0 1 pues de nuevo la
primera entrada sería
sería 112 el primer renglón de a como
columna x el vector 0 0
la segunda entrada sería 0 - 2 1
x 0 0 1
y estas dos entradas conforman a por el
vector 001 ahora a por 110 de nuevo
sería
sería el vector 112
x
y luego sería el renglón
0 - 21 tomado como columna producto
interior con 1
muy bien y finalmente la última columna
de mi matriz a por ver sería
a por este vector que sería
vector columna 1 - 1 2
x 1 - 1
por 112
y finalmente
finalmente va a ser cero 2021
x 1 - 12
así que esto de aquí esto de aquí que se
ve tremendamente complicado
es mi matriz a por ve bien pero cuánto
valen todos estos productos interiores
pues vamos a ver a por ver es igual a la
matriz
ok el producto interior el producto
punto por punto todos estos podrían
llevar un punto del producto punto
punto punto y punto cuánto es el vector
1 - 12 producto interior o producto
punto con 123 pues es uno por 11 más
menos 1 por 2 es menos 2 2 por 3 es 61
menos 26 y acá abajo que tengo cero por
1 es 0 - 2 por 2 es menos 4 y 1 por 3
estrés
acá la segunda columna sería uno por
cero es 0 + menos 1 por 0 es cero y más
dos por uno que es 2
cero por cero es cero menos dos por cero
es cero y uno por uno es 1
ahora acá sería uno por uno es uno menos
uno por uno es menos uno más dos por
cero que es cero
0 por 10 menos dos por uno es menos dos
más uno por cero que es cero
uno por uno es uno más menos uno por
menos uno que es uno
+ 2 por 2 que es 4 y finalmente éste
sería 0 por 1 es cero más menos 2 por
menos 1 que sería más 2 más 1 x 2 es
otro 2 bien ya tenemos algo que se ve
más coherente cuanto es esto pues
finalmente
la matriz a por b va a ser igual a
1 - 26 sería menos 16 que sería 5 043
sería menos 100 más dos es 2001 es 11
menos 10 00 - 20 es menos dos uno más
uno más cuatro es 6 y 0 + 4 es 4 así que
la matriz a por b es esta matriz de
cuánto es una matriz de dos por cuatro
y es esta matriz de aquí ok y déjenme
copio déjenme copio a mi matriz a la
matriz b
3a y a mi matriz b
voy a copiar
y las traigo aquí abajo las traigo aquí
y que si no muy bien entonces la primera
observación que quiero hacer es que como
dije esto solo está definido cuando el
número de columnas en ar coincide con el
número de renglones en b otra cosa que
quiero señalar es que la matriz
resultante tiene dimensiones 2 x 4 2 es
el número de renglones en la matriz
y 4 es el número de columnas en la
matriz b y una pregunta natural es qué
pasa si hubiera tomado el producto debe
por a será que ve por a es lo mismo que
a por b pues veamos de acuerdo con mi
definición
esto sería igual a la matriz b por la
primera columna de a que sería la
columna 10 el vector 10
y ve por la segunda columna de a que
sería menos uno menos dos está aquí
y la tercera columna sería be por 2-1
ahora noten noten que cada una de estas
columnas pertenece a r2 y be es una
matriz de tres por cuatro así que no
tengo definido este producto de una
matriz por un vector puesto que para que
estuviera definido el vector tendría que
pertenecer a r 4 recuerden un producto
de matriz por vector está definido solo
cuando el número de columnas de la
matriz es igual a la dimensión por así
decirlo del vector así que así que esto
no está definido
está
definido
así que no sólo no es igualada por ver
hay casos en los que no está definido
noten que en este caso lo que quería
hacer era tomar el producto de una
matriz de 3 x 4 con una matriz de 2 x 3
y estos números no coinciden así que el
producto no está definido
me gustaría concluir este vídeo con la
observación de que en realidad todo esto
surgió a partir de las transformaciones
lineales y sus composiciones
es decir si tengo una transformación ese
ese que va de r 3 r 2 y elijo estos
números para que coincidan con las
dimensiones de esta matriz y es esta
dada o está representada por s de x es
el resultado de multiplicar a x por la
matriz
ok entonces por eso tiene que ir de r3
en r2 la transformación y si además si
además tengo la transformación t que
ahora va de r 4 en r3
y está dada por de x es igual a la
matriz b por el vector x donde ahí ves
son estas matrices de acá arriba ok
entonces entonces qué sucede pues
hagamos un pequeño dibujo rápidamente
tengo aquí
r 4
4 tengo acá r 3
y por acá también tengo a r2
r2 bien entonces la transformación te
vale r4 en r3 así que puedo tomar un
vector entre 4 y enviarlo a r3 mediante
t y después después la transformación s
va de r 3 en r 2
esta sería la transformación ese
entonces bien nosotros dijimos bueno
simplemente fíjate en todo el recorrido
es decir define la transformación
s compuesta con té
como la transformación que aplicada x
es simplemente toma ese aplicarlo al
resultado de aplicarle t es decir
primero tomate a r3 y ya que estás en r3
toma ese aire 2
bien entonces nosotros definimos esto en
el vídeo anterior
o quizás si en el vídeo anterior
nosotros dijimos que la matriz de la
transformación esté compuesta con t
aplicada a un vector x
era lo mismo que tiene pues que la
matriz a x b x x
y ahora lo que estamos viendo lo que
nosotros vimos es que esto
esto de aquí es representado o más bien
así elegimos las cosas para que esta
composición estuviera representada por
la matriz a por b dejen uso otro color
esto de aquí era igual a la matriz a por
b por el vector x la matriz a por b por
el vector x donde a por b es esta matriz
de aquí así que si no si no cometí
ningún error de dedo o algún error
aritmético en realidad esta
transformación representa la composición
de la transformación representada por
esta matriz y la transformación
representada por esta matriz esa matriz
a por b representa esta transformación
toda esta transformación así que bueno
esta idea quizás no la hayan visto en
sus cursos de álgebra y como les decía
quizás no no sea
está la definición habitual de la
multiplicación de matrices pero en
realidad resulta ser completamente
equivalente de hecho quizás esto se les
haga más familiar a ustedes pero bueno
ojalá hayan encontrado este vídeo
interesante y por favor tengan en cuenta
esto que es la idea esencial del
producto de matrices está íntimamente
relacionado con la composición de
transformaciones lineales y pues bueno
ojalá esto les haya sido interesante